[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum i love this guest we
had met before briefly we didn't really
talk
uh today's guest is just someone that
uh we were going to a convention
together and flying into arkansas and we
thought the plane was going to crash we
thought we were going down and we were
sitting next to each other and we had a
bonding experience
trauma bond trauma bond
kate flannery is on the podcast today uh
she's fantastic you've seen her in the
office and millions of other things
she's extremely funny humble sweet
and i enjoyed every moment with her
didn't you yeah she was really nice
really nice and really fun to be around
right yeah
just a
just a full
what do you what do you say she's just a
the complete package the complete
package is what she was that's right
um
before we get into it just a reminder
that my new podcast our new podcast it's
called talkville tom welling and i have
a new podcast that's called talk fill
ryan teos is on board
every week we watch an episode we watch
every episode of the entire series in
order and then we talk about that
episode like the pilot episode we have a
whole episode about the pilot we talk
about it there's a hotline you can call
in
it's just gonna it's so much fun and
we're so excited and delighted to tell
you about it and hopefully you'll join
us and spread the word july 13th
wednesday and every wednesday thereafter
we will talk
all things smallville i know you've been
waiting for this
it's a big deal act like it
act like you've been waiting for it
because it's uh it's a lot of work
and it's a lot of fun i mean i will be
watching for the first time yeah ryan
will get to watch for the first time so
you get to see how he because he never
watched smallville he never watched it
so it's fun watching uh listening to
what you have to say about each episode
i never know what you're thinking it's a
time capsule man it's a tiny capsule
i love it also look if you guys want to
join patreon go to patreon.com inside of
you
support the podcast uh many people do it
really helps the podcast there's
different tiers
top tier get their names shouted out on
the podcast at the end of every podcast
they get a box full of boxes full of
merch from me
little messages from me and more and
more stuff
so go to patreon.com inside of you i'll
message you back after you join and um
also go to
sunspin.com if you want to get a zoom
from me and rob in the band there's tons
of band merch there i'm on cameo blahdy
blah
thank you for listening if you like kate
flannery stick around
um and uh tell me what you think tell me
what you think and
listen to other guests because i think
you'll really dig it uh let's talk about
the handles that you can follow us and
please write a review it really helps
the podcast
it is inside
we just cut a fart
there's a fart and we cut it but we're
laughing at it
now so sorry about that it's inside of
you pod on twitter and at insideable
podcast on instagram and facebook yes
thank you for listening we love you i
work very hard to get guests and uh talk
about real things real issues
uh adversity that people face and mental
health and all that stuff in between so
thank you for everybody that listens and
supports this podcast
i appreciate you and without further ado
let's just do it let's get inside of
kate flannery it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience do you have purpose do you feel
like you have purpose because that's uh
that's you know it sounds funny it
sounds silly to talk about no i do but
then i get busy with weird [ __ ] and then
i'm like i fear that i've like what am i
doing and then i'm like this is just
recent and i think it's just because i'm
tired and i booked a little too much all
at the same time you are on the go
no but you are i've never seen anyone as
busy as you you it feels like you're
just
i'm like [ __ ] i over i i used to
overbook in town now i overbook out of
town i mean like i literally would be
like running from one show to the next
the next and you know
oh god i mean how do you
do you do it because if you stop you'll
just get depressed
maybe maybe that that's part of it and
some of it's fomo and some of it's just
like that
so much of what we do is connecting to
people and if you don't show up you
don't connect
do you know what i mean yeah i mean i
really feel like the people that don't
go to other people's shows i'm like all
right or but if you're in enough shows
then you see everybody you're in their
shows you know i mean when i when i did
more like you know stand-up nights and
stuff right
do you um do you find it hard to say no
to people
like for instance this podcast you're
wanting to say no i could feel it you're
like i'm too busy i've done a lot of
podcasts but you did it somehow no i
know and i i mean i'd rather do your
podcast than the three other people that
i said yes to that i shouldn't
at least i know you yeah yeah and yeah
that's how it kind of goes yeah so i i
read that you have you have five
well first of all let me let me talk
about the the plane ride because you and
i met you and jane lynch were doing this
morning show as co-hosts or something
for it right right right what the hell
what was that
no we weren't co-hosting you we were
just guests guests but then they just
wouldn't let us leave it was that
hallmark uh
talk show called home and family it's
literally a three-hour show
and you have to like really have the
pushiest publicist in the world to get
out of like doing more than one segment
because they just they want you to do
five seconds give them more yeah
you know we were promoting our tour so i
was like hey
it'll be fun and we've actually sung
live on that show a few times which you
know sometimes it's hard to be able like
to be that to be allowed to to sing on a
show yeah you know how it goes yeah
um so we were you know shaking hands and
kissing babies if you know what i'm
saying like we're just doing what you
got to do right it was a cool little
show was fun but i remember meeting you
there and i was like god she's so full
of energy she's so fun you're like
adorable
you know
if you're 80 i'm adorable uh um or if
you're six uh anything in between i'm
not sure because i remember playing some
stupid sorry we were playing a game like
some made-up game or was it and this
balloon was supposed to pop and i
remember like it and they kept putting
air if you get the and they were sure
that it was gonna just wouldn't pop so i
literally walked up took the my earring
off and just popped the thing popped the
[ __ ] [ __ ] it
that's exactly what you did um
we we then got reacquainted on a plane
we sure did
now jumper
from dallas to arkansas to arkansas and
let me tell you kate if i may say is not
someone that gets nervous on flights
she just is kind of like she's been on
so many so have i i don't really get
never right tell the story
well i i
we were about to land in arkansas
and
we didn't
we just like didn't land the plane just
kind of jerked up it was like what is
happening
and nobody said a word and the pilot did
not say a word forever like we never
remember
we never even found out right but
looking around you can see other people
like were really worried they were
freaking out you looked at me like oh
i was like this is not good and the sky
little i mean we were in tornado country
and it looked like i mean it looked like
tornado country yeah it really did i
feel like are we in one are we near one
did it just happen is it about to happen
what's happening
are we running away from it no we're
just circling it we're circling the
tournament it was scary man it was
really scary it was i was like holy [ __ ]
is this how it's gonna end because you
know when you're flying so much you
think all right well you know what are
the odds well i guess yeah the odds go
up they go up if you fly a lot how many
flights do you think you take on average
a month or a year well last year i
realized i did 53 flights which is nuts
fifty fifty three during a point
and you didn't get covered i did not but
i'm the idiot with the with the two
masks and a shield and i bring a straw
because they don't give you straws on
planes so i just shove that stupid straw
my mask so i don't take it off
i shove the food up there that's see the
dog agrees yeah the dog's upset that's a
good deal yeah um do you uh do you like
do you like cons
i do uh some are better than others so
what do you love about the po about the
cons what do you like about them what do
you not like about them uh
well there is this feeling like you are
in a storefront and people are like
literally walking past you and like
shopping and figuring out if they're
going to spend their money on you which
is really weird yeah you're like oh hey
look at these new pictures i have here
i know you feel kind of weird sometimes
that's a little odd that's the oddest
part and every once while there'll be
some super funny character like just
some odd people that are like
what's going on you're like what's going
on you paid to get in shouldn't you
already know it's like
[Music]
do you have people coming up and quoting
you constantly i do i usually do what's
the one quote that you you you think
that people always say
usually it's cat it's casual day like
they usually give me that
or uh you know
don't fall in love with a big kid that's
another one there's a few there's a few
casual days probably the most popular
right yeah and don't you love the people
that just go hey i don't want anything i
don't want an autograph i just want to
talk to you right and then you're like
great but you don't know how to get out
of the conversation you're okay you know
always tell me it's always difficult i
think i'm i'm pretty good like that i go
hey i love you thanks so much for coming
by and uh i'll talk to you later i'll
see you later take care of yourself i
knew you could take care of yourself i
knew i never worry about you yeah yeah
yeah don't worry about me what about you
well but i know you well you know what i
mean like i got your number like i know
you you don't you don't suffer you don't
suffer i don't think so some people
suffer
do you suffer it's kind of weird it's
it's it's so fun when there's a lot of
people there to see you and you're busy
and you're you know you feel like you're
you feel like you're somewhat important
or you're relevant sure and then that
you could easily feel like [ __ ] right
when all of a sudden there's nobody in
right convention nobody always receives
it
happens it does and actually even
sometimes like when i'm with somebody
from the office like and their line is
bigger than my or whatever but i also
realize i don't talk as long as some of
the other people on the show so i go i
go like oh well if i talk longer then my
line would be longer i don't know
right right but you know but it's also
like it's it's such a champagne problem
because it's doing cons is like this
very coveted position that i have a lot
of
very famous friends that would like to
do them you know you know are you know
fairly well-known actors that like do a
lot of stuff but they're not on the show
or they don't do sci-fi or they don't do
this so it's a weird thing
because you haven't done a lot of sci-fi
are you wizards of waverly place was
sort of like a was that kind of a sort
of yeah that's hilarious yeah i was i
was in the movie cooties where i played
elijah what's up i played elijah what's
mine but i'm going to tell you i would
have had to be a [ __ ] in seventh grade
to be elijah wood's mom i'm not that
much older than allegedly
do you hate when they cast you as a as a
mom and you're like [ __ ] right
i am not that old i mean
again like i'm waiting to get being uh
to be careful
yeah i'm in there yeah you you're almost
there am i almost there oh god did you
hear what she said she said i'm almost
there you're almost the dad you're not
what do you think i am there i actually
would totally well
you know what we're all going in one
direction or we're not like do you
remember we're going to jump in we're
getting older we're getting plastic
surgery and pretending like we're young
i mean like what you know what are you
gonna do yeah do you do you uh worry
about that do you think you say do you
do plastic surgery did you apply the
plastic the plastic i actually had a few
more lines put in i'm just kidding um
i got to keep it up right
but do you do you ever looking do you
look in the mirror and you're hard are
you hard on yourself sure sometimes but
i also feel like i mean i'm the one that
i'm like the idiot when i first started
like i never wanted my pictures to look
too good because i didn't want to walk
in the room and disappoint people that's
what they should have on apps i'm
telling you dating apps i'm telling you
they should they never look as good they
should it's awful it's awful you're
you're setting yourself up for failure
like at least if you're a little under
par and you show people go hey she
puts herself together wow
wow she's going to update her photos
have been kind what
it's a weird thing you know i mean i do
have vanity insanity sometimes but i
also like as i get older you go like
what am i gonna do
what's what's like the worst
criticism you've had from a casting
director
because first of all casting directors
folks are not honest they usually and
i've talked to a casting director about
this usually no matter how bad someone
is like oh yeah it just wasn't wasn't
right for the part did a great job
because they never want to burn bridges
in case that person gets famous of
course of course which i find to be sort
of awful yeah like i want to go
i want somebody to say hey you know he
just didn't have it today he just wasn't
on you want something constructive yeah
it makes you work harder right unless oh
he's great he's great he's great he's
great you were in the wrong town my
friend seriously i mean i'm serious
because people don't want to be that
they don't i don't think they're that
thoughtful and i think it's really about
their they are worried about more
worried about relationships than
stepping on toes although until you
you've obviously made it to a certain
point where they're not afraid to offend
you
yeah but you know it's funny i don't
think i've ever been offended by casting
but i remember i was in between agents
when i moved here from new york uh
gosh this was probably like two years
before i got the office right and i
remember this assistant called
and she said hey i just want to let you
know we're passing on you because of
your age and your looks
and i was like
i mean did they need to say that and i
was like is she reading a card or is she
does she have a head injury should she
not realize what she's saying to me
uh and i was like could you repeat that
because i was like please repeat that
that is like the craziest sentence i
think i've ever heard we are not hiring
you because of your age and your looks
and your looks
she said it again exactly maybe she
thought oh kate's so funny that i'm
going to throw a zinger at her
and she's going to go god that was funny
you are giving this this woman too that
didn't have too much credit but you were
offended you were hurt i was offended
and then
the minute the i became famous in the
office i had her fired i'm just kidding
i know i actually don't remember what
the agency was
right but yeah but it's weird because i
was waiting tables
up and through the first season of the
office in beverly hills so wait a minute
you were waiting tables i was i mean i
was i was like co-starring guest
starring and you're in your 30s yeah
then i was and then i was 40 when i got
the office and i was still waiting
tables because i kept my job that year
um
during season one because we didn't know
if we were gonna get picked up and you
know
right but uh so i just remember like i
remember after the aspen comedy festival
i i did it and i think was 2003 or 2004
and then
oh no it's 2003 sorry and i think um
i just remember having a lot of meetings
after that and then waiting on the
people that um passed on me
and then hearing them with other clients
uh which was such a trip like this one
guy was given this
giving the spiel to a potential quiet
like you're the king and we're just
gonna we're just gonna build you a
castle i was like what the [ __ ] like it
was so weird you're hearing it from the
other side right
and now a word from our sponsor better
help
one of my favorite sponsors by the way
uh ryan what does burnout mean to you
not like you see these guys that are
burnouts
well that's different it's completely
different
just uh being depleted depleted of
energy overworked overworked not making
enough time for yourself yep have you
guys felt burnt out i i know i have i
constantly feel burnt out
it feels to me like
i just don't have energy to do anything
and you know you've got to take time for
yourself you've got to pay attention to
your body your mind and and better help
is there for us ryan i know still uses
better help a lot of my listeners yep
listen to better help um
life can be overwhelming
it sure can and many people are burned
out without even knowing it symptoms can
include lack of motivation irritability
fatigue and more we associate burnout
with work but that's not the only cause
any of our roles in life can lead us to
feel burned out better help online
therapy wants to remind you to
prioritize yourself i don't know how
many times i say this on the podcast be
good to you be good to yourself talking
with someone can help you figure out
what's causing stress in your life um i
know
that i get so in my head
that i sometimes don't know what to do
next i don't i'm overwhelmed with life
i'm overwhelmed and i just tend to go
back into the bedroom and just fall on
my bed and try to sleep it off
instead of dealing with my [ __ ]
if i could say that i don't think better
help it cares it's real stuff here i'm
talking about
but um talking to a therapist talking to
someone someone who's objective someone
who can you know who listen to you who's
a professional
it helps it really truly helps and um
don't take my word for it take ryan's
word for it take take uh all the patrons
and all the people around the world that
use betterhelp yeah take their word for
it yeah
um betterhelp is customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy i
can tell you that especially living out
here in california you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours and
our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
inside
that's better help
better h-e-l-p dot com slash
inside
inside of you is brought to you by geico
geico asks how would you love a chance
to save some money on insurance of
course you would after all who doesn't
love a great deal right and when it
comes to great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life
geico can help like with insurance for
your car truck motorcycle boat and rv
even help with homeowners condo or
renter's coverage you could save even
more with a special discount when you
bundle your coverages plus add the easy
to use geico mobile app available
24-hour roadside assistance and more and
choosing to switch to geico becomes an
easy choice switch today and see all the
ways you could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
i have an agent like that who i i love
him because he really believes in me
right and he really fights for me but
some of the stuff he says is like
it's just like how do you even believe
that like how like i could i can't even
wrap my head around like you're the next
will ferrell you are will [ __ ] feral
you are funnier you're more diverse
you're a dramatic actor and i'm like
going are you on coke what are you on
this guy's brilliant he's one of my
heroes i don't i don't want to be i want
to be half as good as will ferrell i
want you to look at me and i want you to
say you're half as good and i'm like
that's still really good right right
right right because if it's if a
compliment's too high then there's a you
know it's it's we're in hollywood it's
all it's all [ __ ] what do your
agents say to you
uh are they very honest with you they're
pretty honest with me you know i mean
they love you though how do you not love
kate flynn well you're uh
i'm actually my i actually went to
college with my current agent so i've
known him for years we weren't working
together for a while and i worked with
him like god 25 years ago and then
we were different cities and uh
i think we both were having like uh
addiction issues in different areas me
with like you know bad boyfriends
don't get me started
no get started no i start oh cra crate
well this is a part of why i was still
waiting tables because
i got myself into trouble sharing credit
with an ex-boyfriend and uh was like oh
sharing
don't do it kids don't do it you got
yourself in debt because you're spending
yes and then i and then he was like
underemployed the entire time and he's
like i'll pay you back never pay you
know uh and uh you know is that kind of
thing where like i literally had to
declare bankruptcy i'm like we hit the
like i hit the wall because of you and
you know the whole thing well i would do
it for you like that i was just
negotiated out of all my boundaries i
was an idiot yeah um but you know i
again it all takes us like one hopefully
all it takes is one of those people in
your life to be like i will never let
that happen again
so i'm proving to the universe every day
that i'm never going to let it happen
again by putting on this uniform and
waiting on the rich and famous
in between my gift that's gotta be the
worst
it actually wasn't i actually found it
fascinating because again it's like it
it helped me get less intimidated by the
famous because obviously when you're
working on set with people sometimes
it's like holy [ __ ]
have you have you been like that with
roles yeah i mean i remember even on the
office when timothy oliphant uh
was um recurring on our show and i had
well yeah you had a big i had a big
thing with him a big scene with him and
i was like
big thing with him that sounds wrong
that's wrong
i was tuned i was like i was like just
go you gotta just jump jump jump jump
we're just doing this but i had watched
ted wood and i was like you know and
he's a really good looking guy whatever
but you didn't get you got in a little
intimidated yes yeah really did he know
it because i bet he was intimidated by
you well also there's a second city gal
well it was also one of his first days
on the show maybe he was just
intimidated being on the show i don't
know if it was me personally but i'm
sure he didn't google me before but um
which is fine uh i bet he did i don't
know
let's ask him timothy come on out
could you imagine i brought timothy just
for that thank god i didn't say anything
just for that more intimidating than
what i just said oh my god but you know
stuff like so yeah i mean everyone you
know and kathy bates was on the show and
i was like
i know do you say something to her what
do you say what you do
you get starstruck and do you say can i
have your autograph do you do things
like that no no no no no no no we're
working together you know but you also
have to find the common ground and like
you know
and you have to sort of take their
temperature i mean i really she had a
lot to do because she had all she did
was like monologues at first because she
was the the big boss that would come in
so she had these big speeches so it
wasn't about having like short little
clippy conversations with her in between
takes she had a lot in her head was she
nervous she was i could tell she was
yeah yeah but did she do well she was
great i mean she's amazing but this is
the thing she really gives a [ __ ] so
that's why she's an and that's why she
is an academy what like she takes
everything she does super sweet
you know and you're thinking how is she
nervous doesn't it make you feel better
when you see big stars nervous totally
kind of gives you a little confidence a
little bit yeah
that person's a human being absolutely
and everybody has their process and you
know obviously when you're joining a
cast that already exists it's it's got
it's so weird we had a much more
friendly set than most shows like i've
i've been guest star at some shows where
i'm like no thank you like if i you know
and it's always weird when it's an offer
it's like i don't even ask to be here
and this is weird you know what am i
doing here right
it's like thanks for nothing universe
what the hell
it's like i was just minding my own
business and now i'm in this [ __ ] show
well it's because now you're like the
henry winkler of women
you are the kindest people want to work
with you
well you know what it is people that's
the highest compliment it is because if
you know henry i don't know
he's the greatest everybody wants to
work with him right i feel like that's
maybe you that's well do you think
people just genuinely want to keep she's
not as big as fonzie that's like but
that's not my point
flannery is a good time
yeah she's fun to be around she's good
at what she does you know how like when
uh they say the most friendly person on
the set like look out like back away
like i felt like sometimes i was but i
whatever i i i hopefully i didn't have
that reputation but i was like hey but
also i didn't have that many lines most
of the time on the office because i got
to do so much physical stuff so i had
time to chat i was like hey what's up
was it is it kind of fun when there's
not that much pressure on me where you
just have a line here a line there it is
that's the gift because yeah if you make
peace with it if you don't you're in
hell but so i stopped counting lines
like right away i was like no no oh this
is another thing and then i noticed that
sometimes like i get
i get my line cut but i'd still have the
camera they'd still keep the shot to me
because my face sort of i still get the
laugh without even talking right so i
was like i sort of started really
starting to trust that like no no this
is like there's a something else going
on you could have a presence without and
sometimes
kind of like like the steve mcqueen
thing like the less you talk the more
powerful you are yeah yeah
it's true and i hate when long-running
series all of a sudden these characters
have
uh they have more lines and they have
more exposition and that's not why it
was successful they're not even funny
anymore i'm like i never wanted that so
i was really happy that even though
there's a couple episodes where i talked
a little more we never lost that thing
of me sort of being in you know this
like weird little head in the background
making a face you know i i love that
that was still
in the mix because it's very rare you
know happy days was like you know sort
of like what you don't want whatever
there's someone so many of the
characters morphed i mean why am i
picking on happy days but because
you know he never he morphed as well but
he but he always that was a different
like he had a lot of gravitas and he was
you know
he was the fonz you know he was but but
as a person you know he's still to this
day leaves messages michael it's henry i
want to know how you and your brother
are doing i miss you i love you i just
wanted to say hello he's the greatest
that's he'll leave randomly the greatest
it's so sweet he's yeah he's always like
a father figure to me i'm so happy that
he won an emmy for barry oh and i just
started watching season two and i think
i fingers crossed for the next emmy for
henry winkler yeah not that he needs it
because he's the greatest anyway he's
fantastic who made you laugh the most on
the office who who could you barely keep
a straight baby steve steve steve this
is the thing about steve carl he's such
a great actor and he has five choices in
his head for how to do something and
you're like what like it's hard enough
to come up with one or two
and yet like he could make it fresh and
make this choice like i always talk
about there was an episode called office
olympics where michael scott's getting
his condo so he's out of the office for
most of the day so jim sets up like
these silly like paperclip games and
like all this crazy stuff to do around
the office and and we treat it like it's
like it's the olympics
so uh
at the end um of the day we literally
have closing ceremonies and michael
comes in and so he decides to give
michael
a gold medal which is made from paper
clips and yogurt lids that they just
smashed like like the round top yeah
yeah yeah i know you're talking about
shiny right yeah and then they put like
boxes you know the paper um you know the
the
whole you know what
um
you know bundles of paper uh different
heights to make it like right i know
what you're saying gold and silver so
they put they gave michael the gold
medal so he's on top and then they
played the theme to the office until the
two they played the theme to the
olympics and all of a sudden during one
of the takes
steve carell just starts crying
because he's moved by the
written at music of
i'm like that is so funny because i
don't know about you but like the theme
the olympics makes me really like as a
kid i remember being so excited what is
it what is the theme how does it go
[Music]
did you laugh i didn't i tried not to i
don't you don't want to ruin the tank
but you can keep a straight face can't
you you don't break much i'm pretty good
i'm pretty good who's broken you steve
oh yeah yeah he just because you're like
what the hell
who yeah who do you break who can who
can
you break
i don't
um in the cast of the office huh i don't
know
i mean i i always felt i got props from
from rain but i don't know if i broke
him like he he's the kind of guy that
like you'd work on something and then he
would he'd send you uh an email that
night and go like hey that was really
funny or like he or after the episode
area goes he goes that was and i really
appreciated that because it just was
just very thoughtful you know you know
it's funny because rain he's been on the
podcast twice now hey and he
talked about he go he felt like at one
point he was sort of an [ __ ]
on the set and like where he was like
he's like i wasn't an [ __ ] i wasn't
mean to people i was just like in my
head and in a bad place and this and
that do you remember those times
i don't know what you're talking about
i'm scared
you do remember
because you don't know what you're
talking about he says people would know
i'm sure people would say i was mean but
they would say yeah i remember like you
know well yeah i mean he was easy to
make fun of because he was a little bit
of a curmudgeon sometimes but but
i gotta be honest with you i've been on
many sets like the comparison to
you know
some other major douchebags on sets is
you've worked with some douchebags well
yeah i mean let me tell you i i i've
been or i've heard about you know i've
i've definitely heard horror stories
i've not worked with
mark you know
charlie sheen or anybody like that right
but you know
i've heard bad things about jim belushi
you know there's there's a few people to
have like a rep you know but you've
never really seen it on set where you're
like oh my god this guy is a diva or no
not not to no not too bad not too bad
yeah yeah and not that i can if i say
one thing about this you're gonna guess
who it is and i can't say it but
but it but it's not the office um but
hey guys i'm tom welling i used to play
clark kent on smallville i'm michael
rosenbaum i used to play lex luthor on
smallville join us every week as we go
back
way back i'm excited i know are you
can't wait join tom welling and michael
rosenbaum every week as they rewind
every episode of smallville and discuss
their experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast
yeah but you know it's it's a weird it's
not bernie mac
no i loved bernie was he great he was
the greatest i hear that he was the
greatest what do you remember about
working with him uh he was the most
generous he used to have this big lunch
in his room like you know you're
supposed to go to craft i mean to to
catering for lunch and he'd be like hey
come up in our in my dressing room he
has this huge dressing room all the kids
ate there with their moms he had like
different food up there he was like i'm
doing this he was so great he was so
grateful to be there he just made sure
everybody was super comfortable because
there were kids on the show he wanted to
make sure their parents were comfortable
are you kidding me he's awesome he was
awesome wow yeah it makes it even more
tragic knowing how good of a guy he is
you know and it's so funny the episode i
got to do for bernie mac creed is in
that episode creed bratton is in that
episode but he doesn't have any lines
he's like um
he's like a um like um
he's a background actor but he had he
was like a featured background actor
playing a doctor so you kind of just see
like the side of his head or something
was that funny that we're both in the
same episode but i didn't know him then
so i wasn't we weren't in the same space
so i i
you know i didn't get to meet him till
till uh the office but it's so crazy
bernie was the greatest the greatest
just you know were you popular in high
school
uh in my weird way
yes because i i was like a theater geek
uh and i did have a lot of friends i
also have a twin sister we don't look
alike you're younger by a few minutes
yes at three minutes and so i feel like
we
i feel like we got ditched by our uh
friends in eighth grade when we got to
high school because they were like on to
bigger and bigger pastors i was like
whatever
um but
but i feel like we kind of knew
everybody in a good way like i don't
think anybody would so you were were you
a class clown were you funny like you
are now only with like my theater
friends yeah i mean not not so much i
mean sometimes in class but but were you
a serious actress were you like really
because i know you teach shakespeare oh
i did i did right before the office i i
actually i was music director for uh the
los angeles drama that that sounds like
it's kind of like until like you take
things seriously no no it was fun are
you kidding i just was like
a friend of mine there's this great
little theater um
that's owned by the people that own the
magic castle it's behind their house and
i've actually performed there a lot with
the lampshades my comedy act but um
before that uh they started this little
um
one of the sister-in-laws um blair
started this um
los angeles drama club for it was like
kids between like eight and twelve doing
shakespeare so i'm the k i'm the one
that was like we're gonna end every show
with brush up your shake beer like i was
trying to bring some comedy into it
right right right so and i it was good
for me because i hadn't played the piano
in a while so i was like trying to you
know kind of get my skills without you
know
having a practice i mean i practice but
for something very specific and like i
literally was playing for the recitals
it was really fun now you have five
sisters and a brother yeah yep
so i mean what a shock i'm a desperate
redhead you know were you in the middle
were you right i was the end you were
the end but i have a twin so it was like
two of us with the end i kind of feel
like my sister susie was more the
youngest than me but in a way in a way
what what do they all do do they do they
veer away from uh entertainment yeah i'm
yeah so what do you got one's a social
worker yeah my twin sister's a social
worker so i am the evil twin like i'm
like like she is literally like the
greatest person on planet earth and she
also takes care of my dad she took care
of my mom before she died like she's
amazing yeah she's funny she's actually
funnier than i am
are they has your family always been
really supportive of what you do
um my mom was
tough
about because i wanted to to do this as
a kid and she was like no way and i'm so
grateful that she put the brakes on it
because every time i work with a kid
actor i'm like
oh like i just don't some of them are
difficult or just like in their their
their
life trajectory is really um in a bad
spot because some of them don't want to
go to college some some of them think
they're going to be doing this forever
and you know how weird it is yeah you
know you hit 15 and people like
good luck if you're not you know
whatever very rarely do you get to have
a whole career right you started as a
kid
very rare i mean but like growing up
when you're doing plays the whole family
coming to see you yeah i mean not at the
same time just because i my twin sister
and i are five years younger than like
my they had like five kids in a row and
then there was five years and my sister
was the accident and i was a surprise
because my mom didn't know she was
having twins
just kind of crazy did they ever anybody
ever say
kate
give it up you're nearing 40. actually
my dad the very first time my dad was
always super supportive and then like i
think when i was 39 he he literally was
like is there anything else you want to
do
and i was like oh my god if he's saying
this
wow
yeah whoa does that really question
everything you question well it
i i have to tell you or make it go
harder yeah well just like i was already
in it up to my eyeballs and i feel like
i it's not like i was gonna i was still
i was doing my comedy act every saturday
for like we did it like every saturday
for five years and then we would do it
other times during the week too but that
was like our one hour show and
um
you know so and i always had like a
flyer in my
waiter pocket like
and damned if you give it to somebody
and damned if you don't because i'll
beat myself up for like god you should
have oh
why didn't you give
uh
you know uh
robert clary who played lebeau on
hogan's heroes your card why didn't you
actually a lot of the character actors
ended up coming to the show are you
serious i'm kidding you literally um the
woman that played fish's wife on uh
barney or
uh um foreign forget his wife and i'm
i'm i'm ashamed of myself remember
i remember um
uh
and meera and jerry steller came but i
had worked with them before they came um
howard morris who was one ernest t bass
from the andy griffith show but also
from your show of shows
um uncle goofy from your show of shows
you know how howie morris i mean he was
he was the voice of adamant jughead he
was like the greatest like he and he
showed up yeah oh he showed up to a
couple of our shows he came to our aspen
comedy uh tryout and sat in the front
row with his feet on the stage
well isn't that one that you guys won
awards for and stuff yeah well we we
yeah we were we were
we were definitely in the mix i mean uh
you know we we we won like ellie would
like pick a week la weekly awards like
variety kind of stuff yeah yeah yeah
just like you know
uh those yearly paper you know the ellie
weekly had those right you know that's
cool that they all showed up yeah it was
awesome it was let me tell you it was
awesome because i was always more
attracted to i i loved the character
actors that used to come in the
restaurant as opposed to like you know
ann miller you know she used to come in
and like billy wilder and esther will
get a lot of old stars they would never
come to your show nah probably not
that's all right billy wilder couldn't
pick me out of a lineup i waited on him
like three times a week wilder you know
who billy wilder is right director big
director from the from the uh 40s did he
not do rebel without a cup he didn't do
rubble no he did something like it hot
uh um oh my god
he did a million things he did sunset
boulevard oh sunset boulevard is one of
my favorites last weekend yeah i mean
he's he was the guy yeah he was the guy
yeah what was the apartment yeah
favorites
what was what was the one thing where
you go
a project you did where you were like
i'm good i'm good i can do this you know
what i i was doing this uh i was at sick
well um i was in chicago i got hired by
second city i'd studied there i got
hired by them and that's like the first
like where you feel like holy [ __ ]
because there's a lot of people that
were auditioning over and over again and
didn't get it so i i got in the touring
company um and when i was there stephen
colbert was in the touring company and
not that we weren't in the same touring
company but we knew which like there was
there was like three was he great then
amazing i'm always the best always the
best but i remember john favreau was a
host there and i was working with john
in another theater at the annoyance in
an improv olympic but he could not get
hired at second city as an actor he was
just a host which is it's nuts you know
it's so you feel like you get this thing
and it's like this
this um
you know it's a validation right uh and
then um we were doing the show at the
annoyance theater called the real life
brady bunch with jane lynch and then um
and it was uh jill salway at the time
who is now joey salloway um it was uh
their idea and then to do these episodes
of the brady bunch on stage and it was
like this huge hit so wait a minute you
should you actually did episodes yes
re-enacted episodes it was a joke and it
was with the music and did you do the
one where she gets hit in the football
without believing those oh my nose yeah
we did that yeah and i was i was jane's
understudy for carol brady but then i
took over as alice um the maid for a
while and i when i first started i was
doing all the non-very was so
so like there was a line down the block
like you when you got last for that you
were like you knew and it was packed
house all the time every time and then
it went off broadway the show went off
broadway so i went with it for some of
that and then it came out here to the
westwood playhouse do you get paid
pretty well for those shows uh not in
chicago we didn't but but we did i
actually went when when it went to new
york we got paid really well dave
cachner um well first andy richter was
mr brady the first one in new york um
but he would do some episodes in in uh
chicago as well and then dave keckner
took over for him
in new york for a while but um anna
gastar was in the tour with me rachel
dratch did it in new york there's a lot
of like wow a lot of people in it but
what is it i mean when you say you got
get paid well it's still not
like it's not tv money it's not tv money
but it's not theater money yeah
what friends did you meet that you're to
this day were really close everybody
everybody i just mentioned jane lynch
and and um um oh i i just saw rachel
judge a little while ago um dave kechner
um andy richter
hudsol um oh my gosh there were other
ralph garman um i'm trying to think some
of the more
uh
yeah so that's cool yeah it was awesome
it was great yeah and the tour was like
i actually ended up touring it with for
a year we played the kennedy center for
seven weeks which was nuts i just kept
thinking they're gonna kick us out how
many people fit in the kennedy center uh
the room we were in was
uh 500 we were in the
maybe 600
yeah or in the 60s do you get nervous to
this day when you're performing in front
of people whether it's live or whether
it's
what it is it depends what it is what
what does it make you nervous what can
you just do and you don't get nervous
and you just it's easy well when jane
lynch and i performed together we've
been doing uh a live concert a comedy
concert together i don't know what you
call it anti-cabaret act we've been
doing it for
like
almost seven years now wow and there's
some like if we change things if
something's up like every once in a
while get a little bit nervous or part
of it not but not really i'm not
enormous you know you just wing it if
you mess up or something and you mess up
right yeah and the the ball never gets
trapped i mean we're we're perfectly
imperfect it's you know i mean jane is
she's amazing she's incredible do you
ever lose your [ __ ] where you can't stop
laughing
uh
not not usually but every once in a
while i will laugh i mean not that
things don't i that i'm not enjoying
myself but right you know um
but uh everyone so you know one time i
was we were super tired and i i called
her joan instead of jane which is my mom
she was like what and i thought
that's your mom's name yeah
yeah and then i said something i was
like
i was like we're not in high school
anymore this isn't 1996. i was like i
don't know what i don't know what that
oh no i said jane it's 1996 it's 2006.
she's like
no it's not i don't i just made stupid
stupid whatever it doesn't make it it
doesn't translate but we've had some we
had some we have some good times but
what makes you nervous
um i think uh when something's new
like a new show yeah
yeah yeah new material sometimes um
or sometimes when i have to sing where
it's just something that's pretty and i
i don't have the comedy
uh
to fall right yeah yeah yeah you can't
yeah
that's something huh when you when you
have to be serious yeah is it hard for
you to be serious is it hard for you to
be in a moment
it's getting easier as i'm getting older
but i feel like i was so resistant for
years because i also feel like i didn't
really start singing as myself until i
started singing with jane
uh which is kind of crazy but because i
i when i did the lampshades i always i
was like i sing but i i wear a wig like
i'm playing a character you know i'm
making fun of singers so it's yeah i
think there's um
and we did this christmas album that did
really well so i feel like there's
so i have something to like to compare
what i'm doing you know i mean it's like
there's a place to start and also you
don't really stray from from what
we created that people want to that are
kind of coming to hear that yeah which
is good i can relate to that i mean i've
always thought
every situation i tried to make a joke
of it or make it laugh
because maybe because i'm afraid of
intimacy or i'm afraid of
being too serious or like people know me
as the funny guy i've got to be funny
i'm going to let them down that's how i
felt i'm telling we used to do a couple
really beautiful songs in the show and i
remember the first two years
our music director tony tony grinner was
like would you
please because i would make a smart ass
comment at the end of a beautiful song
and like literally we would do this
beautiful song and just as people were
starting to clap i got a great song to
get hi to huh like something stupid like
that like and he's like what are you
doing and then we get like a little
laugh he's like what are you doing
you're like kind of [ __ ] on this
moment you're [ __ ] on this moment
it's because of insecurity yeah yeah i
feel like it's not enough because it's
me that's i know what is that why do we
have that i'm like 50 now and i still
have that sort of empty pocket that i
fall back on that little kid who was
insecure who wasn't good enough but i
still even though i know i'm aware of it
it still happens it's hard i also feel
like it's tough when you see somebody
who i'm sure you've you've had friends
who have come up through the ranks who
like suddenly have notoriety and started
and they start taking themselves way too
seriously you're like yeah i don't want
to be that i don't even want to get
close to that yeah i hate that or
i would have done things differently
like i would have brought me along well
there you go right you know what i mean
how many of those friends you go like
why are you bringing me along for that i
mean right why don't you give me that
role why don't you give you
well
well that's that was my i hate to be
that guy but there's some times where
i'm like
come on throw me a [ __ ] dog
dude that's why i came up with the
lampshades with my with my comedy
partner scott because i was like the
phone is not ringing like i gotta come
up with something like i gotta get my
own thing apparently so and you know i
mean there's a gift in it if you look at
it like that like you get off your ass
you actually can create your own [ __ ]
yeah yeah there's like sometimes
underlying thing is like well
it would have been nice to get a phone
call you know really yeah you know and i
hate to be that you know that person
that's just like oh you know just do it
for yourself go get your own success
beat him with success i'm like yeah but
you know it's just all sudden you're
doing this and it's like
do i suck that bad no no and then you
know it's funny because it's funny i've
been listening to a lot of audiobooks
lately i know this is so crazy but i was
just listening to the talking of happy
days i was listening to gary marshall's
book and penny marshall's book
and it's so funny because they came from
the bronx and they literally for
um when when gary was working on um
first on the odd couple
he created this this little like
tutorial
so that their his friends could come and
pro help produce the show he had like a
manual for them because he knew they
were smart and they just didn't do it
before and and so that's why he brought
his friends along on happy days and
laverne and truly to produce that's what
i would do but dude he literally paved
the way i'm like so few people do that
and if you know somebody's talented it's
a shame yeah and there's also the trust
factor you know you can trust this
person maybe my friends just don't
[ __ ] trust me that's all i can i
don't know i mean oh look look i
understand if there's a there's a
there's a movie and there's four actors
in it sure you wanna and you know i'm
not exactly yeah and you gotta have a ba
and you wanna draw there's 40 actors in
a [ __ ] movie totally totally you know
yeah yeah i mean yeah so it is it does
it is a little disconcerting to say the
least and i i see it on both sides it's
certainly something that i've learned to
accept over the years but it is a little
bit like a you know it's a kick in the
balls sometimes sometimes i feel like
it's paulie and um from rocky paulie and
what's her name adrian yeah
what do you mean he's just like he's
like you know what do i owe you paulie i
do you laundry i do this
remember that scene of course but like
you know he's like you know maybe it's
like you know what do i owe you i don't
know anything i don't know maybe i
no and the thing is like
really i mean we're
it's nice when you can bring somebody
along but yeah but i always try to do
that that's just me yeah whenever i'm on
a project if there's some like i'll
bring my friend up for five lines i'll
bring you know if i was the lead when i
was the lead on the show yeah i'll bring
my other i got my other friend producer
session and he got the part um i got my
friend's song in a smallville episode i
got that's awesome you know uh
like my movie i put so many of my
friends right even if they had very
little to do right i wanted you know
that i loved you and i'm putting you in
here and actually
the one person i really fought for on
the office to get a part was my comedy
partner from the lampshade scott
robinson he became the he was the
bartender at poor richards for the
second last episode it i it took me all
those years to to the second last
episode but i was so happy it worked you
know and you know and i thought about it
wasn't a bigger part but still you know
um but yeah i'm totally
yeah yeah i totally get you do i sound
like what's the word do i sound like
bitter
when i talk about that
a little
drying's like i sound better
well my microphone's on the floor but
yes
yeah well
but i'm not saying that i just i always
feel that way but i'm just feeling like
sometimes yeah i think you're honest and
i think it's i and i i don't think you
live in that neighborhood i don't think
you you're bitter all the time no no no
no i'm just like i've noticed in my past
or i'm like yes huh it's like wow that
would have been
you know what bothers me or would've
been easy when other friends validate
what i've been thinking and i don't say
anything and they go
i don't know why you're not in that role
yeah or i don't know why you're you're
not getting a call yeah it's funny
that's so funny who's also a mutual
close friend of that other person right
you're like i don't know talk to her
yeah yeah it's funny it's funny yeah i
remember seeing a movie
uh a few years ago that i i had read for
a part that that and then they ended up
changing the part so it or the part
didn't exist anymore but anyway it still
would have been nice to do another part
and i remember see i i saw jane at the
she was not in the movie either and she
goes well that was a great movie how
come we weren't in this and i was like
wow if she's saying this i know because
we knew a few of the people involved
that's life she said that yeah you get
your feelings hurt that's just that's
just like it's just like i think it's
because hey i've done this long enough
i've proven haven't i proven myself
that's right and then i'm like okay i
guess you don't see that that's okay
right that's okay i know you know what
are you gonna do you gotta let it go and
go hey i'm gonna beat him with success
yeah or obviously have my own success
great for them i love you i want you to
be happy right and clearly i you know
i'm i'm i'm supposed to be doing
something else you know what you know i
mean i i feel like you know
it's uh
again it's like um
we have to i feel like my the biggest
job i have as an actor to watch my
expectations all the time
because otherwise i'd be in hell yeah
you know it's a it's a big job it is it
is i mean i think you know that's when i
i'm less and less encouraging the young
talent but because i always bring that
up i'm like you got to be careful
because
if you're you have to be persistent but
you have to be pleasantly persistent
because if you're angry persistent
nobody wants to do it
i always feel like i just want to be the
most fun to work with you're going to
love me the crew's going to love me it's
going to be a great time i'll fit in
just nicely i know it's it's i know
that's so true that's right i i always
that's what i don't like about gas
starring is that it's hard it's
sometimes you're just there for a day or
two it's harder it's hard to know to get
to know the crew so you're like yeah
like i don't remember anybody's name
guest stars have the hardest draw you're
coming into a family that's everybody's
done and you're starting and everybody
all eyes are on you yeah that's not fun
i know and then i feel like people are
fans of the office and i'm like hey you
know what and then they feel whatever i
just like i'd love to to i wish we had a
little more time yeah a little more time
to hang yeah yeah yeah what uh for sure
you don't seem like the kind of person
that would ever have an addiction
problem with you know like alcohol or
drugs or anything like that you just
don't seem like you ever would uh i
played a drunk for nine seasons michael
you did play one on the office yeah but
it came pretty well you know what i did
you ever have drinking problems no well
you know i always i dated guys with
drinking probably you know i i shot a
lot of them are you yeah i used to be
not anymore i i i gave up but yeah i
mean obviously my dad owned a bars
there's been a lot of alcoholism in my
family well flattery
darling in philadelphia if you can't
type stereotype here we are
uh
so true my dad's bar was like an old man
bar it was uh it's so funny i was just
talking to my sister the other day about
um my dad had all these guys that lived
above the bar and um if they couldn't
make rent he'd let him work it off he
was like the friend of the forgotten man
because he got sober in the 60s like
sort of sort of he was he didn't go to
a.a but he he figured out um because he
was drinking too much and he saw days of
wine and roses that jaclyn movie and it
scared the [ __ ] out of him and that's
kind of what got him sober
um but i just you know so he wanted to
help these guys not any he didn't try to
get them sober he just want to make sure
that they you know didn't die in the
street right that was kind of thing some
guy broke into my dad's station wagon
and fell asleep my dad found him and
gave him a job and a place to live for
the next 35 years
polish guy are you kidding me i [ __ ] you
not my dad is a [ __ ] character and
this is one
he's a good guy he really is and you're
taking care of him right now well i'm
i'm my sister susie's taking care of her
i'm back you help here yeah i'm back and
forth i try to get through i try to get
there at least once a month um because
yeah he's 98. geez i know he's amazing
he's amazing still has all his marbles
so um which is important but i just
remember like there was a guy that
worked for my dad after you know he had
some bad luck and he was i think he was
a carpenter and he was working around
the bar and he had he got cancer of the
tongue they used to call him joe tickets
because he always had raffle tickets
everybody had a nickname joey tickets
yeah right and then he became well i
called him tongueless joe because they
had to remove part of his tongue and he
used to answer the phone
how are you doing
yeah like
tongueless joe oh it's kate hey right
well did you really call him tongue to
his
like a good catholic girl i waited
behind his back but i remember being in
the car we were driving down we were
driving to the shore and i was like an
hour and a half drive and joe's in the
passenger seat my dad's driving and i'm
in the back and joe says
and my dad goes
he wants to know if you fish
my dad could understand everything
and i said um
uh no i i don't
not really my dad goes
she says she doesn't fish
like he's here let's check his earless
joe
all right this is called [ __ ] talking
with kate flannery these are my patrons
the lovable patrons who give back to the
podcast uh patreon.com inside of you
thank you for all the love and support
guys and supporting the podcast these
are rapid fire if you want yes uh leanne
any fun behind the scenes memories from
dancing with the stars which we didn't
really talk about um
you know that that had to be
nerve-racking it was i was just saying
that was not fun backstage it was it was
it was like it was like going in front
of a firing squad every week that's how
it felt it was nuts was it exciting it
was exciting and it was uh some weeks
were like triumphant because i was like
oh my god because i got i did get the
highest score a couple weeks which is
nuts because you lasted five rounds yeah
and i was the oldest um person for most
of the show wow which is nuts you know
and then i got most of the tournaments i
got 50 well i i
i i was 55 that's pretty old all the
other women were in their 20s except for
jesus mary wasn't and she got uh she got
cut the first week so it was yeah and
it was nuts and then i did i got 54 of
the 80 shows on tour and we got cut
short um a little bit pandemic yeah but
i did 45 of the shows so i only missed
attention which is not it's nuts i mean
did you feel like you're in the best
shape of your life yes absolutely was it
was it were there times where you were
with your dance partner was his name
posh posh pasha yeah were were there
times where you just felt like i can't
do this yeah i i can't i'm gonna yeah i
literally was like my body does not like
i i didn't i wasn't gonna quit but i was
like we gotta figure something out
because i'm not getting that step like
we i would love to and again like i wish
i wish i'd had six months training to
get because i i was so out of shape when
we started i was not doing cardio
imagine i'd put on a little weight i was
like holy crap you know it's like i
literally said it is and i literally say
i did that show because i'm too cheap to
join a gym enough
i was like i want to be a negative
afraid but they weren't interested sorry
assistant making it afraid
um but i actually it's but it was it was
it was an interesting challenge and it
almost becomes almost like a like a
religious practice where you just have
to like it's the only thing you can
focus on there's not there's like
nothing else on the menu you just have
to work on that because otherwise
it will never work
it's crazy it's crazy can't imagine
doing that i can't it was it was that it
was it was it was a really interesting
experiment i mean it's the weirdest show
do you whisper things in your ears while
you're dancing like okay ready here we
go sometimes yeah yeah or
he'll or he'll do the four four five
like he'll do like count five yeah he's
like
some people are counting really loud you
know
yeah yeah that looks yeah lamar odom's
uh dance partner was screaming like that
like two three like
how long did he last uh
i think
two
three maybe two or three two or three
two three yeah because people just
wanted to see more yeah
i guess yeah but did you feel like you
were like hey i'm holding my own here i
did i did i did and i had another weird
i don't even know if we should talk
about this but my season sean spicer was
on and literally um the former president
was tweeting for people to uh vote for
sean so that's why he i
should have been on for at least one
more episode but sean
yeah so son of a bee isn't that weird it
is that administration literally was
affecting my it was very strange well
just think you know i was just watching
the uh the eyes of tammy fay oh yeah
yeah i remember how they talk about how
reagan would call jim baker and say hey
you know can you speak on behalf of me
and everybody to vote for reagan so he
had millions and millions of people in
his congregation or supporting his
church and you know for reagan wow so
you know that's you get somebody like
the president going hey vote for sean
spicer you're kind of [ __ ] waiting it
it's nuts yeah it's not emily s favorite
episode of the office to film ever
uh i'm gonna say um moroccan christmas
because that's the only time steve and i
actually had a full scene that we got to
improvise usually everything was really
written and you would improvise within
your lines once in a while but that i
think they were going to put a voiceover
of the whole thing and they end up
keeping some of the you know some the
adr but yeah that whole uh chase scene
when meredith gets dragged into rehab by
michael scott that was that was such a
blast
such a blast loved it so fun steve's the
best um
this is one we were sort of talking
about may k one of my favorite meredith
moments was in season seven episode
titled the sting you were hilarious as
meredith van helsing trying to seduce
timothy olivine's character danny uh
history
right are there any behind the scenes
stories from the episode that you
remember
and uh did you like working with tim
uh i did like i wasn't i was definitely
nervous though because
he's a very intimidating i mean he's a
beautiful he's a beautiful so beautiful
i did my first movie with him oh you did
so funny um and like i said i i had been
watching deadwood so i was like
um
uh but yeah i just remember um i there
was a point where i was like touching i
was like oh dear god like i was
i wish i was a little less nervous
because i think i would have touched him
more but maybe it's better i didn't i
don't know i like touching people like
you know sometimes it makes them
uncomfortable you know i was touching
his ear a lot
no no i know it's just weird i was like
trying to
wet my finger and put in his whatever
you know that's horrible
but things that you should never do to
anybody know that now that we have a
pandemic you'll get this i don't get
this hannah h i would truly like to know
if you support any rabies non-profit
organizations
um uh you know what i i was just wearing
my um um meredith palmer celebrity
rabies uh whatever michael scott
i i never know what i really should
practice that's that t-shirt that
michael scott had made for the uh fun
run
uh for rabies awareness um i i don't but
i will i will i'm going to hannah don't
worry i'll i'm on it i'm on it if you
have a rabies charity please let me know
i'll
i'll get up um when you won a sag award
as a cast yes two sag awards yes do they
give you separate awards so you can put
them on your mantel yes they do they do
and they each we share no they weigh
like 80 pounds they're nuts it's nuts
like and then you're carrying it around
and with your long dress it's a it's a
it's a [ __ ] it's winning's a [ __ ]
it's just
so hard
now they've talked about you know you've
heard about this stuff like reboots
because they reboot a lot of things do
you think the office will be i don't
know
i don't know you know i think that is it
up to steve correll it is up to sea but
and and yes and greg daniels but i think
that there's we have two big obstacles
one is that they're we're so beloved and
there's a feeling that it things wrapped
up so perfectly that it's like there's a
sacredness to it and another the world
has become
more pc than ever and michael scott a
lot of what he's said may not fly
right so i that's what i would be
worried about you know what's next what
are you doing now because you're doing
oh you're doing so much what's going on
uh well i i i just finished a movie um
that i my stuff was shot in alaska um
you went to alaska i did how was that it
was insane i was we were shooting in
this very fancy um log cabin
uh but it was cold and it was crazy and
it was like it was a we had to shoot
i had to be so prepared we did so many
scenes a day because of the weather you
have to be we had to be a lot of
dialogue yeah yeah it was it was fun
though but it was it was like
it was intense and matt walsh is in the
movie too it's called the bolt from the
blue it hasn't come out i'm not sure
what's happening and i just had a movie
that um
um was just at south by southwest called
the prank with um rita moreno um wow
uh you know what we we were not in in
scenes together but i did
you meet her i did she's the greatest
and funny it's funny because i just saw
her last week at um lilly tomlin's
handprint ceremony at the church are you
friends with lily tomlin i you know i
did a play that she pretty she and jane
produced right before i got the office
wow yeah so um and she was very
supportive of um the lampshade she had
us perform at the uh
at the
you know the big closing night party
have you had good conversations with
lily tomlin i have i have she's the
greatest she's the greatest did she ever
talk about her incident with uh
what's his name on the set david uh oh
oh oh david o russell i used to wait on
david o russell was he nice he was
always nice to me which is interesting
because usually people that blow up will
blow up at waiters but i i we also had a
mutual friend so maybe he was nicer to
me at the restaurant but that scene is
incredible isn't it that much i heart
huckabees oh my heart huckabees if you
haven't seen if you go online
tomlin kind of lashes out at him and he
lashes back at her and he goes pretty
overboard oh yeah but of course you
never brought that up no why would you
ever bring that up i would have brought
that up no it's funny because they
listed it that she has so many movies
and ben megawits i'm actually friends
with ben mykowitz from tcm he introduced
jane fonda who then introduced lilly for
the thing and he mentioned iron
huckabees and i was like oh
what are you bringing up that movie for
you know like yeah yeah but uh what do
you what else do you want to do i mean
you're still very young you have a long
life ahead of you what is it you want i
want to be the character i you know what
i really want to be um i did an episode
of magnum p.i this past year oh yeah
it was a blast it was a blast what is
that film uh uh the big a
wacky you know oh what a treat yeah it
was amazing it was amazing and the best
cast ever they literally took me out to
dinner twice when does that ever happen
to you a guest star on a show and they
take you out to dinner i mean they're
awesome
um but yeah i i um you want to go back i
do want to go back but i like be i like
the idea of being the character person
on a one hour i love
um there's a few people that do it
really well and i feel like it's it's a
it's an interesting place to be because
you get to be funny but it's not you
know there's not like pressure it's just
i don't know it's would you do a drama
yeah that's what i mean like a drama
like a character procedural or a drama
yeah but you don't want to the heavy
load you don't want like tons and tons
of lines every week i don't know i don't
need to be that
yes let me be yes wouldn't that be the
dream and and if somebody else has
something to prove it's all yours it's
all yours prove yourself go ahead go for
it
uh this has been a really treated big
tree did you have fun it's it's been a
real treat
for me too did you hear me stumble you
did and i uh yeah you know what they say
what do they say if you stumble then
you're lying i'm just kidding was i long
i didn't have fun i don't know i feel
bad this i feel like this flew by i
didn't mean that's good i didn't ask you
anything dude well what you supposed to
do is my podcast because i want to ask
no question well what do you want to do
next
i want to dance
um
i want you know i uh
i can make some calls for you
you really want to dance
for you i i honestly
i got the wrong process i think that in
the beginning we were talking i don't
know if we were recording oh yeah the
purpose right oh yeah purpose yeah i
don't know if we were really happy we
were having a purpose i think that i'm
working on that
do you have you have you felt like
you've had a purpose in the past no i
i'm not sure but i i feel like
i'm not
you know a lot of people from the
podcast have said you know hey this
podcast really helps me and affects my
life and yes because you ask good
questions well i don't even know but
it's like enough people have said this
that i really feel like okay this
that should be purpose that should be
some purpose there helping other people
of course you know helping others so i'm
still you know i'm still working on
myself i'm still working on you know
what i think is going to make me
ultimately happy that's a kind of a
funny word happening of course you know
it's like you know who's really happy
and i always think well happy people i
guess right but you you want to be
you want to be content you want to be
successful you want to you know you want
a peace of mind yeah and also some some
some room for for joy i want to say i'm
doing this and i'm really happy about
this yeah i'm proud of this yeah and
this is what i want to do totally it's
been a while since i've been like this
i'm so excited this is like music kind
of makes me feel that absolutely i like
music i totally get i'm never going to
be a rock star i'm never going to sell a
million records but i do love playing
music i have to say the same thing like
when jane and i get to sing together
it's like one of the great joys of my
life and i know we're gonna be doing our
christmas tour this year how many albums
have you done together just one just one
christmas album the christmas album but
we we're we just booked three
uh three dates at joe's pub at the
public theater in in december we're
gonna be doing and then um i know we're
playing like chicago and like we're
we'll be doing another full tour i'm
sure for christmas but it's you know
it's it's joyful like it's it's
there and there's this thing that like i
i feel like it's it's um
it's so it's so much of the unconscious
music is like it's so unconscious which
is what i like because i feel like i'm
sometimes i'm too conscious and that's
exhausting yeah you know i'm like like
thinking about this and not like am i
doing this right am i you know who's you
know what what should i be doing am i
doing the most with what i've got like
are we making the best of this time
because i feel like especially in the
last couple years like i don't know how
much longer we have on this planet it's
a weird time
there's a lot of people that are like
jumping it's weird it's weird yeah yeah
i feel like um
my like my parents how you know when
you're in the 80s they're
talking about how bad the 80s are and
the music was really 70s and 60s sure
you know and sure and i think that i'm
like no the 80s were the best times
right no they really were no that's so
they were just so much fun and
individuality and right the music was so
diverse and right it was just like so
funny i and i really i won't backtrack
on that i won't go back
because i really feel like it's far
better than the music now
there's some great performers i agree i
feel like that whole essence of the 80s
yes was just a pleasant time and maybe
i'm wrong maybe the parents will go you
don't remember reaganomics and right you
don't remember the iron contra you don't
remember all these and the aids and the
you know but we were young then and and
so our conscious i mean what we were
really aware of you know i mean i i i
there was connection
yes there was connection you you had to
you know you say hey i'll meet you at
the theater at seven and hope that
they're there right you didn't you could
you didn't make you didn't text or
change or double check you just there
was intuition we actually used our
intuition to find each other at the
airport like how did that happen right
exactly
we did yes and now it's like the tick
tock and the you're on there for hours
and it's like you know you could be
doing so many other things can i do it i
don't know i'm like micromanaging these
things that don't amount to [ __ ] i just
wish there'd be more connection i just
wish that you know it wouldn't be all
about uh you know the internet and what
funny videos people are showing i wish
they i want more connection maybe that's
more you know i'll have more purpose
right the more connection we have right
let's just destroy the internet as well
destroy the internet yeah
maybe that's what elon musk is going to
do because he bought twitter uh
something's going to happen i don't know
it ain't gonna be pretty
uh because he ain't that pretty uh you
know what's funny i was thinking
as a kid uh we were talking about tv
shows i remember feeling like i after
like shows like mash and mary tyler
moore i wanted to be on a comedy that
had a great finale and i just feel so
lucky that i got on a show that had a
great finale like a like a long-range
[ __ ] like that and that's so rare
because i feel like
i feel like there's so many comedies are
kind of dramatized now
or they're just not that funny even game
of thrones had a bad and yeah right yeah
so i don't know so i feel like
everything else like when i'm really in
gratitude and like when i'm i'm not
comparing myself to somebody they're
like oh
you know you didn't call me for that um
you know which is like you know
keep your eyes on your own paper that's
like a good thing to do just don't go
there because when it's a slippery slope
once you start doing it
it snowballs into some way wait a minute
um but i also think just like looking
back and thinking okay what did i do
that really what what how did i really
make my dreams come true and i've done
that a few times yeah so yeah i feel
like that too i feel like i mean there's
that i always say haven't i done enough
well haven't i done enough isn't it when
is it enough
when is it you're like hey
you made people laugh you entertain
people you were on a show you did this
you're good i know you're a good brother
you're a good grandson you're good well
can't you just be content can't isn't
that enough right what else do you need
yeah but some reason i feel compelled to
need more well maybe there's another
chapter waiting for you that you got to
get your ass off and get off your ass i
can't talk i think i need to fall in
love oh well there you go
does love change the game it does you
know i bought my boyfriend on the office
he was a still photographer uh in nbc
and he would come on so i feel like i
was like i was playing like you know i
did not get a great wardrobe or a lot of
makeup on the office if you noticed the
first season i was like i'm never going
to get laid working on the show and i
ended up meeting like my boyfriend it
gets crazy
yeah a couple people like from the first
season one remember that i remember you
said that i was like i meant it
oh my god i'm never gonna get laid
working on this show
that's how i felt when i was on
smallville i'm bald and i'm like you
know no good girl only goth chicks are
gonna like oh
do you feel like you when you're in love
16 yeah do you feel like when you're in
love i hear this that it reduces your
stress levels yeah it does why is that
you know what i think there's
well it depends if you're in love with
somebody who's crazy in a really [ __ ]
up relationship then ignore what i'm
saying um because that i i was there and
that's not
that's not optimal i mean you you know
you can do better that's what i'm saying
um but i do think it does um
uh
i think there's just
i don't know i don't know what it i
someone calms you if it's the right
person yeah they calm you when you're in
stressful situations i assume that's
kind of i think that's that's it and i
think it it uh
it's it's a reminder that we're not just
here to do stuff and work hard you know
i mean like i think what did they say
like we're not a human doing we're a
human being like you can just be right
and i feel like that other person helps
to remind you you could just be
you know words of wisdom from kate
flannery let it be i love it best i root
for you i think you're a terrific person
yeah i'm sorry you weren't my i just did
a comic con with oscar ninjas last week
and it was like uh the craziest
uh group of people it was like bobby and
cindy brady bionic woman and what six
million dollar man are you going to any
are you going to st louis con i'm not
are you going to uh illinois metropolis
know that you're not going to that no
are you going to australia are you going
to
uh maybe added later but also okay well
we'll we'll meet up again i'm sure by
the way if i i'm having a birthday
party on july 10th if you're in town
it's a sunday and it's an 80s band the
spasmatics are going to play i think
taylor dane might play what yeah so it's
going to be like a fun 50th birthday
party so i'll invite you thank you and
you'll have to come all right yeah this
has been a real treat lastly i'm gonna
i'm gonna ask you three tv shows you
give me the theme song okay mash
i'm
all right give me this is a tough one
okay
little house in the prairie
um
[ __ ]
uh because it i it all it almost sounds
like the theme to the new heart show not
the bob new hard show but the the um
the you know the second bob newhart's
here
oh [ __ ] um
uh
uh
i hate myself
down here no that's dallas
give me the love boat theme
love
exciting and new
come aboard
expecting you you know
if you go to
the li if you go to long beach
the princess
instead of like the old whistle it plays
the theme to love boat we were just down
we were in long beach a couple so we
were laughing so people that live in the
neighborhood they want to kill the boat
company
i don't blame them
uh i love you thank you thank you
michael you're awesome bye you're the
best
it was great she's great she's great i
mean she was a great guest she was
someone who was humble she was open i
really appreciate it thank you kate
flanders for being the podcast thank you
for uh holding my hand when we almost
died in the plane crash going down in
arkansas but uh it didn't crash we're
alive
we're still here thanks for taking a
photo that was fun i'll post that too
yeah right yeah it was nice of her yeah
she's a nice woman yeah what are you
gonna do
uh uh another reminder
the big talkville
podcast
tom welling and i the new podcast ryan
will join us i am there too every week
we will talk we will watch smallville an
episode and then talk about it
join us starting wednesday july 13th and
every wednesday after
um spread the word it's going to be a
lot of fun there's a hotline you can
call us leave messages
blah blah we can't wait to join you or
you you to join us on this uh
amazing um
journey journey journey
thank you generally
uh
thank you to all my patrons uh go to the
inside of you online store for awesome
merch new zip ups uh new glasses
drinking glasses inside of you
autographs anything you need there's
scripts autographed by me there's so
much great stuff on that on that website
it's really
it's really grown
my shopify account has really grown let
me tell you there's a lot of cool stuff
on there um thank you for listening
right now these are the top tier patrons
these are the people who give the most
to the podcast and i'm going to give
them a shout out here we go nancy d leah
s sarah v little lisa yukiko jill e
brian h nico p robert b
you ready for some more let's do it
jason w raj c joshua d cjp jennifer n
stacy l jamal f janelle b kimberly e
mike eldon soprano 99 more 99 more san
diego m chad w leanne p janine r my p
matty s belinda and chris h dave eight
sheila g brad d ray
h tap the t tom and liliana a talia m
betsy d chad l rochelle marion med k dan
and big stevie w angel m rhiannon c
corey k super sam dev next and michelle
a jeremy c andy t cody r gavinator david
c john b brandy d yeah boar correct
yvore camille s the c joey m willie f
david h design
otg otg eugene and
uh leah correct
chris p nikki g cory nicole heather l
jake b james b
bobbitt megan t mel s orlando c john b
caroline r rob e paul c christine s
sarah s eric h spring jennifer r shane r
m r mark m
jeremy v andrew m robert g
zatucci 77 and andreas
n
andreas
and uh i don't know what i would i would
do without my patrons
you guys really help support the podcast
and i thank you and i say it every week
and i'll say it again thank you i love
you it means the world to me and uh the
big podcast talkville coming soon man
coming soon so
make sure you support that one if you
will
uh we're gonna need your support and
love and uh follow us and write reviews
and
send in questions and it's gonna be a
big family affair
that's what it's gonna be like mary j
blige did she sing that
i believe it was it's a family affair
okay i can't think of how it goes you
want to hear the i think the theme song
now i i changed it i decided this is the
theme song
what is this is uh right here
it just starts
you're listening to talkville
it's from a new song off the new album
but it'll be just an instrumental
version but it's a song called i'll go
to heaven
but i think it's it just gives a little
energy a little spark i like it i like
it better than the other thing we were
working on but we could always try
things great let's do it yeah you know
what i'm saying i don't know
why the hell not thank you guys uh from
the hollywood hills in hollywood
california i am michael rosenbaum i'm
ryan taylors yeah i get a little wave at
the camera
uh thanks guys
promise me you'll be good to yourself
and uh have a great week thank you for
making me part of your week um
and keep listening that's all i could
say if you don't know a guest that i
have on here i hope that you'll listen
anyway and learn something about them
and not just say i don't know them see
ya
because it really helps when you listen
and spread the word so all my love to
you continue the love
and uh ryan
i'll see you next time get some rest man
you too yeah
[Music]